a double strike in Hollywood that could
ruin your favorite TV show thousands of
actors grinding America's entertainment
industry to a halt after hitting the
picket line and joining the writers
who've been there for months tense
negotiations with the major Studios said
to have suddenly broken down right as
The Summer's hottest movies like Barbie
hit the big screen the A-list cast of
one of those movies Oppenheimer let
their films left their big Premiere in
the UK to write up some strike signs
themselves so what's this beef all about
apparently a lot of it has to do with
artificial intelligence actors worried
that their likeness is going to be
replaced by a robot Union president and
former star of The Nanny Fran Drescher
explaining that one
if we don't stand tall right now
we are all going to be in trouble we are
all going to be in Jeopardy of being
replaced by machines these companies
haven't done nearly enough to provide
for the consent of performers to the use
of their digital replica and likeness I
mean the idea that these companies
should be able to take somebody's voice
their face their body and just control
that and use that without meaningful
consent it's anathema it's unacceptable
and there'll be no deal unless that's
resolved technology was heavily involved
in our last story in a great way
technology seems to be involved here as
these actors are worried about money
from streaming and AI how do you how do
you think about this it's a weird thing
because what what there were you know
what they're talking about in some ways
is that if you if you are an extra you
get your uh you only get paid once it's
like hey I'm going to be I'm an extra
I'm going to do like 10 movies this
month no they might just take your face
and make you an extra in everything else
and you get paid for that but you might
not have been paid at all if you didn't
get that job so it's it's kind of like
maybe they pay you more I don't know
it's a fair point I don't you know the
thing is the writers have been on strike
since May and now you got the uh you've
got the actors and it's hard to tell if
people are noticing it right to people
aren't like it's not like it's not like
in the I think Somebody went on strike
and he ate it like with sports go on
strike everybody notices it right but
you don't notice it now and it's because
we created such a silo
a backup ration of entertainment right
it's like what you don't need mediocre
new TV if you can watch if you can binge
watch all of Colombo which is amazing or
The Rockford Files which I would do it's
like it's like there's so much stuff
that maybe a strike is necessary for all
of us to catch up I will say the five is
safe you can't replicate this you know
this is not normal I'm not normal Harold
you are not no none of us are normal and
why and it's because AI is based on
predictions being being able to best
predict uh human behavior and do it Matt
as mathematically you know as fast as
possible and you can't we're too
unpredictable as humans at least we are
not the view
as old as as 1960 was the last time the
writers and the actors went on went on
strike together but as far back as that
was uh 60 something years now it was all
over movies playing on television and
how actors would get paid for it here we
are now dealing with a similar thing how
do you some people have told me that my
timing is impeccable uh you know days
before I go to eight o'clock every
writer and every actor in America goes
on strike I have no competition all
scripted shows are going to be stale you
have to watch me now I'm just saying uh
I'm just very fortunate person
I remember years ago when people all
throughout the Heartland were
complaining that their jobs were being
taken away their jobs were going to
China Indonesia Mexico and all of these
factories were leaving
and no one in Hollywood said a damn
thing about it they just watched these
people lose their jobs and their
livelihood and Donald Trump came along
and he said let's bring these jobs back
and they hated Donald Trump for that and
if you read Fran Drescher she's saying
the exact same thing Donald Trump said
she's out there saying this is a Moment
of Truth these big businesses and this
new technology has taken these jobs away
from us and it's time to stand together
she didn't stand together when everybody
else was losing their job uh when the
Keystone Pipeline workers lost their job
or the miners in Minnesota or any of the
card guys all the stuff went to Mexico
so it's a little too late in my opinion
but I'm it's happening to her and this
is probably the last Union that's been
affected to this type of radical change
Kayla yeah uh Hollywood actors want to
be paid more I mean Cry Me a River here
this is ridiculous I don't watch
Hollywood award shows because it's left
dispatting one another on a back this
strike has just left us and fighting
that's what this is it affects the
caterer most it affects the crew members
most the people who depend on their
paycheck all because the people at the
top want more money is what it comes
down to
um I think it's crazy not only that they
say we can expect further delays in
upcoming film releases okay um upcoming
film releases my family will survive we
don't need Hollywood but you know what
we couldn't have survived the essential
workers the health care workers showing
up during the pandemic the Meat Packers
showing up during the pandemic they
showed up to do their job but Fran
Drescher wants to sit there she called
herself a victim today she called All of
Hollywood actors victim I don't think
most people in America look at them and
say victims we're going to miss your
movies
Emily yeah I think that's the reason why
so many people find the actor's argument
so unpalatable because they're
essentially saying Cry Me a River you
who are worth 160 million dollars but
the value in it for this contract
negotiation and disagreement is the fact
that they are now becoming the
figurehead speakers for the guys the the
writers and the like that are showing up
every day day in and day out making very
little money and if you put this
conversation into the rubric of yes it's
entertainment it is considered the
creative arts or the Performing Arts if
we keep it there just for a second it's
interesting to sort of talk about the
notion of whether the big studios can
use your likeness in perpetuity can you
show up for one day they use your image
as much as they want you get paid one
day if you are hired not as the
scriptwriter anymore but as the editor
for a script that AI generated and
interestingly Sarah Silverman and a few
others are spearheading a lawsuit where
they are suing the big studios saying
the reason you have the compilation AI
does is that like they used my content
that the reason AI as you as you put
forth that it sort of mathematically
generates this content it's because it
has mined the internet for the content
so the artists are saying that was my
content to begin with so now this is
just a derivative but it does go into
the point you guys are making where this
new streaming ecosystem has sort of
undermined a lot of these guys salaries
and the question is who cares and also
America probably doesn't because to your
point I'm fine watching reruns of the
same stuff I'm fine reading I'm fine
watching some stupid YouTube video it's
the studios it's these guys that say I'm
an artist this is my craft that tend to
care a whole hell of a lot more than we
do you know what's weird about this
whole segment is that Harold LED it and
I think that was on purpose because then
no one asks you any questions about this
topic but I I look at you and I know
what's going
I know what's going
[Laughter]
you think about our cinematic history
and you took the last hundred years you
talked to CEOs in America who were born
outside this country they all talked to
how TV's American TV and American movies
influence and introduce them to American
way of life I hope they get to the
bottom of this I do think even if the
American people don't care about it
they're making a great point and you
made it with the Sarah Silverman piece
they shouldn't be able to do this even
if we think they're hypocritical even if
we think they're disingenuous at times
it may be wrong what's happening but
whatever the case hope they figure it
out because I want to see some new
movies coming up Joe Biden getting
questions about the way
he wrapped his overseas trip oh no
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now